imaginen que tienen un objeto en frente
de este espejo cóncavo si queremos saber
en donde se forma la imagen podemos
dibujar los rayos de luz que rebotarían
en el espejo un rayo que podemos dibujar
es uno que vaya paralelo y cuyo reflejo
pase por el punto focal pero estos rayos
son reversibles
no tengo que dibujar este resulta que si
enviamos rayos de regreso por donde
vinieron van a recorrer de nuevo la ruta
que usaron pero en sentido contrario así
que estos rayos son reversibles si envío
un rayo paralelo va a pasar por el punto
focal y si envío un rayo a través del
punto focal se va a reflejar paralelo en
otras palabras no tengo que dibujar este
rayo puedo dibujar el rayo que va de
este punto pasando por el punto focal y
éste va a regresar paralelo así que voy
a dibujar este por diversión y voy a
dibujar otro para poder encontrar en
donde se va a formar la imagen voy a
dibujar este de aquí esta línea blanca
se llama eje principal y se dibuja en el
centro de éste
pero curveado y ahora voy a dibujar un
rayo que vaya desde aquí hasta el centro
del espejo porque yo sé que la ley de
reflexión dice que el ángulo de entrada
tiene que ser igual al ángulo de salida
y los ángulos se miden a partir de la
línea normal y este eje principal
resulta ser una muy buena línea normal
al menos para el centro de este espejo
ya que es perfectamente perpendicular a
él así que puedo usar esto para mi
beneficio yo sé que el ángulo de entrada
tiene que ser igual al ángulo de salida
por lo que solo tengo que asegurarme de
que este ángulo de salida pues sea igual
al de entrada por lo que estos dos
tienen que tener el mismo ángulo que le
llamo theta y para encontrar en dónde
estará mi imagen pues se va a encontrar
en donde ambos rayos se cruzan así que
la punta de mi objeto la vamos a ver en
este punto de aquí y tendremos una
imagen que está de cabeza así que
haciendo estos trazos podemos encontrar
más o menos donde tendremos la imagen es
yo puedo calcular a ojo en dónde estará
este ángulo pero quizás tenga un ligero
margen de error si yo quiero saber con
exactitud en dónde se va a encontrar la
imagen necesito de una ecuación en donde
yo pueda poner los números como la
distancia a la que se encuentra el
objeto a partir del centro del espejo y
cuál es la longitud de este punto focal
y como resultado me dé la distancia
exacta en donde va a estar mi imagen y
es lo que vamos a deducir en este vídeo
esta ecuación se llama la ecuación del
espejo y nos dice cómo relacionar la
distancia al objeto con la distancia de
la imagen y la longitud del punto focal
vamos a hacerlo como la deducimos si
ustedes la buscan en un libro de texto
va a aparecer es un poco complicada
aunque realmente no lo es tanto aunque
la primera vez que yo la vi realmente
dije esto es una brujería matemática no
le entiendo nada pero realmente no es
tan mala como parece vamos a comenzar
dibujando triángulos
noten que estos dos ángulos son iguales
y vamos a usar esto para nuestra ventaja
vamos a dibujar un par de triángulos que
tengan éstos como sus ángulos digamos
que están a partir de esta imagen hasta
el centro del espejo y desde el espejo
hasta la parte de arriba de la imagen y
desde la punta de la imagen hasta la
base de la imagen así que imagínense
este triángulo rosa de aquí es un
triángulo rectángulo ya que aquí tenemos
un ángulo recto y tiene a theta como uno
de sus ángulos pero puedo dibujar otro
triángulo que tenga este ángulo theta y
que va desde la punta de arriba del
objeto hasta el centro del espejo y del
centro del espejo hasta la base del
objeto y finalmente de la base del
objeto hasta la punta del objeto de
manera que ahora tenemos este triángulo
azul que también es un triángulo
rectángulo ya que aquí tiene un ángulo
recto que también es un triángulo
rectángulo porque aquí tiene un ángulo
recto
en otras palabras ambos son ángulos
semejantes ya que ambos tienen este
ángulo theta y ambos tienen un ángulo
recto en otras palabras si a ustedes no
les gustan los triángulos semejantes
piénsenlo de esta manera podemos usar
una función trigonométricas elija en su
función trigonométricas favorita
yo voy a elegir la tangente aquí tenemos
la tangente de theta yo sé que la
definición de la tangente siempre es
igual al lado opuesto entre el adyacente
el opuesto a este ángulo que vamos a
tomar de este triángulo primero el lado
opuesto a esta teta a que es igual este
lado pues es la altura de la imagen que
le vamos a llamar h y esto me dice que
tan alta es la imagen así que esto va a
ser igual a la altura de la imagen
dividida entre el lado adyacente a este
ángulo de aquí que es esta distancia de
aquí y es
qué tan lejos se encuentra la imagen del
centro del espejo y le vamos a llamar de
a distancia a la imagen y se mide a
partir del centro del espejo no desde
esta parte del espejo de aquí sino desde
el centro del espejo se mide desde este
punto de aquí y este es el lado
adyacente a este ángulo así que aquí
ponemos de ahí que es la distancia a la
imagen pero esto sólo fue para la teta
de aquí abajo tenemos que hacer lo mismo
para la teta de aquí arriba esta teta es
la misma que la de aquí abajo por lo que
puedo usar esta misma relación para la
tangente de theta yo sé que la tangente
de esta t está también tiene que ser el
lado opuesto entre el lado adyacente
pero el opuesto a esta teta es este lado
que es la altura de mi objeto así que la
llamamos h la altura del objeto
así que el lado opuesto de esta theta es
h
y lo dividimos entre que pues entre este
lado que es el adyacente a este ángulo y
este lado es la distancia del objeto
hasta el centro del espejo le vamos a
dar un nombre
y en efecto seguro adivinaron que va a
ser de o la distancia al objeto
nuevamente esto lo medimos a partir de
el centro del espejo no de la porción
curva que sale del espejo sino de la
parte central del espejo este es el lado
adyacente así que aquí escribimos de hoy
y aquí tenemos una relación importante
esto solito tiene un nombre no es la
ecuación que estamos buscando pero es
muy importante esta parte de nuestra
deducción se llama la ecuación del
aumento aunque en general no se escribe
así
la tienen como h dividida entre h
y esto es igual a multiplicamos ambos
lados por d y nos queda de y entre de o
esta es la ecuación del aumento y nos
dice cuál será la altura de la imagen
pero queremos encontrar qué tan lejos se
encuentra la imagen del centro del
espejo pero esta ecuación que acabamos
de encontrar nos va a decir qué tan alta
va a ser esa imagen
así que si despejamos la altura de la
imagen ésta va a ser igual a la altura
del objeto multiplicada por cierto
factor y este factor será la distancia a
la imagen dividida entre la distancia al
objeto aunque noten que esta imagen está
invertida
así que si definimos esta distancia a la
imagen como positiva ya que está del
mismo lado que el objeto tendremos una
imagen invertida que sería como una
altura negativa por lo que si queremos
representar imágenes invertidas con un
valor negativo tendremos que escribir
esta ecuación con un signo negativo
adentro y decimos que la altura de la
imagen es igual
a menos h o borde y / de o o podemos
poner el negativo acá
de esta forma sabremos que si obtenemos
un valor negativo para la altura de la
imagen sabremos que está de cabeza en
otras palabras si el valor que obtengo
de h
fuera de menos tres centímetros
significaría que tengo una imagen con
una altura de tres centímetros pero de
cabeza es decir invertida esto es lo que
representa el negativo pero bueno esto
no es lo que queremos deducir queremos
una fórmula que nos dé la distancia a la
imagen con base en la distancia del
objeto y la distancia focal por lo que
necesitamos hacer otro conjunto de
triángulos y ahora lo que haremos es en
lugar de considerar estas tetas de aquí
vamos a considerar estos ángulos de acá
no les puedo llamarte está porque estos
ya los nombres aquí a estos vamos a
llamarlos fin estos ángulos también
tienen que ser iguales
ya que cada vez que tenemos una línea y
tenemos otra línea que la corta
estos ángulos de aquí siempre serán
iguales así que haremos lo mismo que
hicimos para theta pero ahora con estas
y formamos dos triángulos y cada
triángulo tendrá un ángulo fin para el
primero tendremos esta altura del objeto
como el lado opuesto de aquí acá
tendremos otro lado
y de aquí a acá tendremos otro lado y
como necesitamos otro triángulo que
también tenga afín vamos a usar este día
que de aquí a acá luego de aquí abajo y
luego de regreso a fin así que tenemos
dos triángulos este triángulo y este
otro triángulo ambos tienen a fin y
ambos tienen un ángulo recto por lo que
también son triángulos semejantes y
hacemos lo mismo decimos que la tangente
de esta fin va a ser igual al lado
opuesto entre el lado adyacente el lado
opuesto a esta fin es este lado que es
igual a h
así que escribimos h dividido entre el
lado adyacente no es de hoy ya que este
lado solo llega hasta acá no llega hasta
el centro del espejo así que esto es la
distancia total al objeto menos esta
sección de acá si restó esto de la
distancia al objeto la cantidad que me
queda será el lado adyacente de este
triángulo por lo que esta distancia
desde el espejo hasta el punto focal
tiene
y se llama distancia focal y la
representamos con una efe y quizá esto
los confunda ya que f me representa
tanto el punto focal como la distancia a
este punto a partir del centro del
espejo así que éste también me
representa esta distancia por lo que
este lado adyacente podemos reescribirlo
como la distancia al objeto menos la
distancia focal ya que esta parte de
aquí es el lado adyacente la distancia
al objeto menos la distancia focal pero
sabemos que está fe es igual a esta otra
fin por lo que puedo tener la tangente
de fin por lo que ahora la tangente de
esta fin va a ser el lado opuesto y cuál
es este lado este lado del triángulo es
igual a la altura de la imagen por lo
que esto la tangente de fi que es igual
al opuesto entre el adyacente en esta
ocasión el opuesto es la altura de la
imagen h dividida entre esta distancia
de aquí
que es simplemente la distancia focal
por lo que el lado adyacente de este
triángulo
es sencillamente la distancia focal
dividimos entre efe de manera que ahora
tengo dos ecuaciones que juntaremos y
obtendremos la ecuación del espejo hay
diferentes maneras de proceder a partir
de aquí lo que yo voy a hacer es que no
quiero ni h
en ninguno de estos por lo que vamos a
despejar este de aquí para h
/ h de manera que me queda h / h y
imaginen que dividimos ambos lados entre
h y multiplicamos ambos lados por d o
menos
efe y me quedan h / h y es igual a de o
efe que es la distancia focal dividida
entre la distancia focal y puedo hacer
lo mismo aquí arriba h
/ h y es igual a de o / d
por lo que dividimos ambos lados entre h
y multiplicamos ambos lados por d pero
lo que está en este lado de aquí es
igual a lo que está en este otro lado
aquí abajo por lo que sabemos que h
/ h
de o menos efe / efe
y aquí sabemos que h / h es igual a de o
/ d
lo que significa que está de o menos efe
/ efe es igual a de o / de y ya que
ambas expresiones son iguales
entre h y todas son iguales entre sí
porque todas son iguales a lo mismo
h / h y ahora vamos a resolver esto
vamos a limpiar el lado izquierdo me va
a quedar el lado izquierdo de o / efe -
1 ya que a menos efe / efe es igual a
menos 1 y esto tiene que ser igual a de
o / de dividimos ambos lados entre de o
y me queda 1 / efe ya que la de o se
cancela esto es igual a menos 1 / 2 y
esto es igual a esta vez se cancela con
esta otra de hoy y me queda uno / de iu
y ya lo logramos aunque normalmente esto
se escribe con esta 1 / b y de este lado
derecho
1 / d en ambos lados nos queda
finalmente la expresión que queremos 1 /
efe es igual a 1 / de 0 + 1 / de por fin
la expresión que queremos 1 entre la
distancia al objeto más 1 entre la
distancia a la imagen es igual a 1 entre
la distancia focal es una fórmula
bastante sencilla y nos requirió un poco
de esfuerzo llegar a ella pero esta es
la ecuación del espejo y relaciona la
distancia focal del espejo con la
distancia del objeto en otras palabras
si sabemos qué tan lejos se encuentra el
objeto del centro del espejo y conocemos
la distancia focal del espejo podremos
encontrar con exactitud la distancia a
la imagen a partir del centro del espejo
en lugar de en calcular la más o menos
dibujando los rayos que se reflejan esto
nos permite encontrar la ubicación de la
imagen con exactitud y si la usamos en
conjunto con esta ecuación del aumento
también podremos encontrar la altura
exacta de la imagen y quizás se sientan
un poco incómodos con este
lo negativo que puse acá como podemos
saber si cualquiera de estas cantidades
es positiva o negativa bueno pues la
convención que estoy usando y que usan
muchos libros de texto es que las
distancias focales van a ser positivas
para espejos cóncavos como el espejo que
tenemos acá este es un espejo cóncavo
pero si tuviera la curva hacia el otro
lado sería un espejo convexo y aquí
tendríamos una distancia focal negativa
lo que tiene sentido ya que si el espejo
tuviera la curva así el punto focal
estaría por aquí de este otro lado
estaría atrás de este espejo por lo que
tiene sentido que sea negativo y la
distancia al objeto si se encuentra del
mismo lado en donde tenemos el ojo ya
que si usamos esto correctamente nuestro
espejo debería estar de este lado
veríamos al objeto aquí pero también
veríamos la imagen de este objeto justo
aquí y si el objeto se encuentra del
mismo lado en donde está nuestro ojo que
sería lo correcto la distancia a este
objeto sería positiva y básicamente
siempre será positiva a menos que
tengamos un conjunto de varios espejos y
esté pasando algo extraño con los
reflejos pero si tienen solo un espejo
no hay ningún problema esta distancia al
objeto se define siempre como positiva
usando las convenciones que usamos acá
aunque nuevamente hay otras convenciones
que ustedes podrían usar pero esta es la
que se usa en la mayoría de los libros
de texto la de iu es un poco curiosa de
y va a ser positiva también si es que
esta imagen se encuentra del mismo lado
en donde está nuestro ojo como tenemos
aquí esta distancia la vamos a
considerar positiva porque se encuentra
de este lado si la imagen se formará de
este otro lado del espejo por ejemplo
acá tendríamos una distancia a la imagen
negativa si estos fueran cinco
centímetros atrás del espejo la
consideraríamos como una distancia a la
imagen de menos cinco centímetros si
usamos esta convención de signos con
esta ecuación del espejo tendremos una
relación correcta entre la distancia al
objeto la distancia de la imagen y la
distancia focal y si usamos la misma
comprensión de signos
en esta ecuación del aumento también
obtendremos la altura correcta de la
imagen y si esta altura de la imagen
resulta negativa entonces sabremos que
la imagen se encuentra invertida y si
por el contrario esta altura de la
imagen sale positiva sabremos que la
imagen se encuentra derecha
en resumen usando varios triángulos
semejantes pudimos deducir una ecuación
del espejo que relaciona la distancia al
objeto la distancia a la imagen y la
distancia focal y además deducimos la
ecuación del aumento que relaciona las
alturas del objeto y de la imagen con
las distancias al objeto y a la imagen
tenemos que ser muy cuidadosos con los
signos aún cuando la distancia al objeto
casi siempre es positiva la distancia
focal puede ser positiva o negativa la
distancia focal será positiva para
espejos cóncavos y será negativa para
espejos convexos las distancias a la
imagen van a ser positivas si se
encuentran del mismo lado del espejo en
donde se encuentra nuestro ojo o en
frente del espejo y serán negativo
si se encuentra detrás del espejo y de
nuevo esta no es la única convención de
signos que pueden usar pero es tan buena
como cualquier otra y es la que se usa
con mayor frecuencia en los libros de
texto